Bayside! Hey!
Yo Mama. Sorry, Dr. Mama.
How do you thinkthis year's gonna go for these new students?
I'm psyched.
- Are you're excitedfor the first day of school?
Why is everybody so rich?
- Are you readyfor my party Saturday night?
I got DJ Khaled's baby to make you a playlist.
It'sokay.
Time out.
What is up with these kids?
-In attendance will be the Governor of California.
Mac's dad?
You look amazing! Your hair is fire!
My dad'salso coming.
I don't care about your dad, Spencer!
Ijust care about Zack and Kelly!
We all want thesenew kids to feel welcome.
Can we talk?
Did you just sit backward in a chair?
Wow, I've never seen anyone do that in real life.
- It's not gonna work unless we get to know them.
You only know how Bayside works
for kids likeyou.
- Hot kids?
- Privileged kids.
Bayside is where I finally felt like I belonged.
This place is magic.
Damn, I love magic!
- Hey Max, I actually ordered
cheese on mine.
Take a look in your pocket.
Does this place ever stop being weird?
One, two three!
The old gang back together again!
Will you go to dinner with me?
-Oooh!
-Stop eavesdropping.
We're not, we're the Bayside a cappella group
(singing)
Ah, Bayside.
You're the man coach, when
I grow up I want to be just like you
a single childless adult who parties with kids.